when spider-man officially joined the
mcu back in 2015
fans were understandably excited about
the prospect of seeing some classic
comic book villains finally get some
silver screen love
those fans got exactly what they wanted
too with a vulture appearing as the main
antagonist
in spider-man homecoming alongside
classic foes like shaka
and the tinkerer shortly followed by
mysterio in spider-man
far from home meanwhile sony pictures
has attempted to develop a handful of
other spider-man
villains into their own independent
projects starting with 2018's venom
and continuing with the upcoming jared
leto flick morbius
so far most of the other sony pictures
projects such as silver and black
and a solo mysterio film appeared to
have vanished into the ether
but one project that supposedly still
lego is a standalone craving the hunter
movie
fans have long waited to see the
nefarious big game hunter on the big
screen
but there hasn't been all that much news
about the project in recent months
a 2020 report from deadlines suggested
that jc chandor was in talks to direct
with a script by equalizer scribe
richard wank but that was the most
recent major development
until now that's because according to a
recent rumor shared by the illuminati
marvel has allegedly made a formal offer
to keanu reeves for the role of craven
in his own standalone movie
to be clear neither sony nor marvel have
responded to this rumor
so you're best taking it with a massive
grain of salt but if true
it would be the biggest development for
the craven the hunter movie to date
on top of their potential casting scoop
the rumor site also reported that the
tone of the film will be a mix of man on
fire and logan
the illuminati stressed that this is
only an offer so far however
and didn't give any indication of
whether reeves has accepted or not
on at least one level though it is
absolutely true that marvel studios has
courted reeves for a number of projects
in 2019 marvel president kevin feige
told comicbook.com
that many discussions with reeves had
taken place and that
i don't know when if or ever he'll join
the mcu
but we very much want to figure out the
right way to do it and while it would
make sense that sony might want to nab a
big star in the role
it's also unclear whether craven would
be the marvel character reeves would
finally want to pick
particularly since the connection
between sony's standalone flicks and the
mcu
remains unclear regardless if reeves
were being courted for this notoriously
over-the-top character
it would be an entirely different beast
from the kind of roles he's generally
associated with
it's worth saying again that this is a
totally unsubstantiated rumor
and neither marvel nor reeves have
commented on it indeed one reason to be
skeptical is that it's unclear whether
the standalone film is moving forward at
all
or if sony is waiting to see how mobius
first or even more confusingly
whether craven might instead appear in
an mcu spider-man movie
after all it was said that sony was
pursuing that solo mysterio film back in
2017
but the character instead appeared and
far from home and then there's reeves
himself
who's a busy guy to say the least among
the most prominent of his upcoming
projects
include the matrix 4 in december 2021
and
john wick 4 in may 2022 yeah
i'm taken on back after that he'll be
appearing in a fifth john wick film
he's also involved with two more
upcoming films rally car
and past midnight as well as the tv
series rain
sony hasn't officially confirmed that
craven movie is happening at all
much less shared a timetable for the
project but if filming was to take place
before 2023
reeves would have a difficult time
fitting it into a schedule
especially given the heavy demands of
featuring in a marvel film
and given how difficult it's been to
bring reeves into the marvel fold
thus far it might not be time to bust
out the craven cosplay
just yet check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos by your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you